[Musik]
seit generationen und kämpfen menschen
für eine bessere gesellschaft
wir bringen die aktivistinnen und
aktivisten aus verschiedenen
generationen ins gespräch was eint was
trennt sie für frauenrechte kämpfte
schon in den siebzigern christina perri
juli gern auch mal mit radikalen mitteln
irgendwo was abgefackelt haben haben wir
auch als frauen hab ich halt prioritäten
gehört es von der toll
heute will meyer burger wird vor allem
mit aufklärung für gleichberechtigung
sorgen auf social media für minister
kämpfer auf peter auf instagram in den
verschiedenen plattformen
[Musik]
du hast ja selber eine ziemlich
erfolgreiche plattform in die erklär mir
mal und dann machst du ja eigentlich das
was was dir auch geholfen hat nämlich zu
erfahren was gibt es für definition also
wir haben sozusagen verschiedene themen
wochen zu verschiedenen themen also zum
thema anti rassismus für minister muss
et cetera und wir haben verschiedene
begriffe erklärt eigentlich mir ein
digitales glossar für jeden aktivismus
ist es ja wichtig wissen zu sammeln und
zu vermitteln
egal ob im netz oder in büchern auf
flyern und deswegen sind wir hier am ff
witz das ist ein dokumentationszentrum
wo die zweite welle des feminismus aber
auch die folgenden gesammelt und
ausgestellt werden welche rolle spielt
denn für dich die geschichte des
feminismus ist spielt eine zentrale
rolle also ich sage immer das was wir
heute machen können dass wir das nur
machen können weil vor uns heute den weg
geebnet haben das von oft irgendwie
meine generation auch denken machen ihm
was viel krassere sphere radikaleres
aber viele der dinge die wir heute
machen gab es auch schon vor 50 an
[Musik]
wie beurteilen sie denn das wie ist das
was sie in der zweiten welle geschaffen
haben in die nächste generation gekommen
ganz vieles ist nicht mitgekommen was
denn es ist ein gefühl dass dieses
anarchistische militante autonome dieses
auf sich selbst heraus konkret arbeiten
also nicht jetzt nur vermitteln was
richtig ist
das ist ja schön diese instagram der
geschichten aber ermutigen die frauen
ermutigen die macht wieder zurückzuholen
zu den frauen kann ich voll verstehen
also es kann ja auch gleichzeitig
funktionieren dass man sagt helma macht
sowohl irgendwie politische bildung im
digitalen als auch andere form der
arbeit im analogen eine wichtige
unterscheidung sehe ich auch darin dass
die neue bewegung unter sexueller
orientierung zb endlos viele
aufsplitterung nelson piquet und hat ja
gar kein ende
wir haben diese unterscheidung nicht
gemacht also sie sagen der diese
aufsplitterung aber was bewirkt die denn
ihrer meinung nach man macht doch viel
kaputt wenn man die leute immer den
schachteln tut du kannst jedoch nicht
entwickeln wenn werden
die festlegen lassen aber ich kenne das
von oft dass ich selbst in schubladen
gesteckt werden und das ist voll der
selbstermächtigung moment ist zu sagen
hey ich bezeichne mich selber und diesen
begriff am ende ich für mich und nicht
andere personen für mich
[Musik]
der feminismus der zweiten welle der hat
ganz verschiedene temperamente
versammelt und da gab es eben autonome
radikale manche sind später zu
terroristischen vereinigungen über
gewandelt wo ist die grenze wie radikal
darf aktivismus sein ich habe lange
mitgemacht in einer blase die aktivismus
um des aktivismus selbst pflegte
das war eine denkfaulheit ja das war ein
menschliches gehabe und ich habe
wirklich erst mit der hat
anti-atom-bewegung gelernt dass man
andere aktionen machen muss die mut
erfordern und öffentlich sind wenn dem
die anderen die eben heimlich sind
scheiben ein schmeißen oder irgendwas
anzünden und davonrennen
das ist einfach nur sachbeschädigung ich
bin zwar wichtig anzuerkennen dass
aktivismus voll viele verschiedene
formen haben kann ich finde aktivismus
ist genauso meine oma zur
ausländerbehörde zu begleiten des
aktivismus auch nicht so ein mug atom
ist sondern dass es auch voll sensibel
sein kann um zu wirken muss es schon um
außergewöhnlich sein und das ist dass
wenn jemand mut öffentlich das ist das
was andere überzeugt und auch beflügelt
und den bringt man oft nicht auf und man
macht dann einer demo ja die ist für
mich für die katz
gemeinsam ist beiden bewegungen dass sie
räume brauchen früher frauen zentren
heute community spaces zum aufnehmen von
videos oder podcasts
als sie eben sich als lesben organisiert
haben also sowohl als frauen erstmal da
wurde ihm von den linken kommilitonen
gesagt ihr spaltet die arbeiterbewegung
als sie dann innerhalb der frau und sich
als letzten organisieren wollten da
haben manche gesagt das ist ein
luxusproblem und ihr sie sollten sich
lieber mit den waren frauen problemen
beschäftigen
aber dann müssten sie doch genau
eigentlich diesen internationalen
feminismus total gut verstehen für mich
ist es andersrum
es ist eben nicht mehr die frauen erst
mal das wichtigste sondern die frau und
dann noch dass die klassenfrage und dann
noch die rassenfrage und dann aufatmen
die frau vergessen es versteht sich so
es wird zu beliebig aber das ist ja
genau was die linken kommilitonen ihn ja
auch gesagt haben wollen die anderen
tourismus ist wichtig die klassenfrage
ist bleibt wichtig es ersetzt die
frauenbewegung nicht in meinen augen
aber internationale versuche tun das ja
auch nicht sondern sie erkennen an dass
die identitäten von menschen komplex
sind du kannst ja auch von der identität
nicht ein lesbischsein abtrennen und
sagen das ist jetzt was anderes und
deswegen das meint feminismus immer
geknüpft an meine identität als
gastarbeiter in nachkommen als migranten
deswegen ist es umso wichtiger dass ich
dass wir sagen alles ist wichtig aber
ich glaube was frau julie wenn ich sie
richtig verstanden habe ist er so der
pragmatische ansatz also womit reißen
wir am meisten damals war das sehr
konkret es gab keine frauen zentren ist
gar kein frauen notruf nö
das haben sie alles erreicht und was
gibt es an solchen praktischen konkreten
dingen im leben zu erreichen für eure
generation also wir müssen ja immer noch
überhaupt das fertig kämpfen was schon
die ganze zeit gekämpft wird bewegungen
wie christopher street day wird das auch
die sichtbarkeit von diesen themen
existiert und alles aus dem digitalen
genannt haben also um itu bewegungen das
gehör verschafft wird für diese themen
natürlich gibt es politische forderungen
die wir irgendwie möchten aber nicht
komplett jenner neutrale sprache zum
beispiel aber frage mich gern in 30
jahren noch mal was sie alles erreicht
haben
ich weiß nicht ob sie alles so machen
ich mir das vorstelle aber das ist
wirklich nicht meine auf
aber das zu kontrollieren
[Musik]
[Gelächter]